Now that we have our level set up with our landscape imported and a few of our actors like our lights and our fog
Let's go ahead and now talk about editing our levels
And the first thing we're going to talk about in level editing is going to be camera bookmarks
Now camera bookmarks are a really useful tool that allow you to specify
Where your camera should be looking at and gives you a really easy way to come back to that location
Now we can access our camera bookmarks a number of different ways
The first way is through the hamburger menu here
If we click on this we'll see our camera bookmarks and then we have jump to bookmarks one through nine
Which we can also set bookmarks using the one through zero keys on the keyboard
And then we have the ability to compact clear or clear all of our bookmarks now
We can also set bookmarks manually by hitting ctrl plus the one through zero keys on the keyboard and again
Bookmarks are a great way to come back to a certain area inside of your level
So let's pop over here to the editor now and go ahead and set some camera bookmarks
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna come over here maybe to like this little peek over here
And then I'm gonna hit ctrl one on my keyboard. You can see here. It says saved a bookmark
So whenever I press one, I'm gonna automatically come back right to this location
So let's go ahead and we're gonna set one maybe like over here
So I'll hit ctrl 2 and then maybe I come down here and we'll set one maybe over here
So we'll do ctrl 3 so I've got one two three
And again, I can set these all the way until the zero key on my keyboard
And you're gonna find these really useful for a number of different things one
we can put these in areas that we know have a low FPS or a low frame rate and
Always come back to this to kind of check this area to make sure that our frame rate is
Matching our target we can also use them to chart our levels progress
one of the cool things that you can do is let's see we come back over here to let's say
Two if I hit f9 on my keyboard you see here. I saved this screenshot
So let's go ahead and open that up really quick and we can see here. This is a screenshot of that location
So again, I can use these camera bookmarks to help me do things like
Chart my levels progress or always
Come back to the same location to check my levels
Performance to make sure that everything that we're doing inside of our level is performing the way that we want it